- Les démineurs du Service
d'urgence d'Ukraine sont
en forte demande. Autour
de Kiev, les batailles ont
laissé des millions d'objets
explosifs de toutes sortes.
Chaque matin, les équipes
reçoivent une affectation qui
ré a a aux demandes des élus
des zones affligées.
Il faut d'abord éliminer
les mines antichars que
les Ukrainiens ont semé pour
freiner les blindés russes.
Ce sont des mines défensives,
légales. L'avantage, c'est
qu'on sait où elles se trouvent.
Les Russes ont perdu énormément
de véhicules blindés : plus de
3000, dont 500 tanks au moins.
Certains ont été abandonnés
ou capturés, mais la plupart
détruits, comme ceux-ci.
Il faut s'assurer, avant
de s'en approcher, qu'ils
ne présentent aucun risque.
Les Russes tenaient une position
ici pour lancer des roquettes
sur la ville d'Irpin où se sont
déroulé les combats les plus
acharnés. Mêlés aux débris
des blindés et aux déchets
laissés par la garnison russe,
possiblement des explosifs,dodos
avancent avec prudence.
Les habitants voisins ont
vécu des semaines d'horreur.
Les tanks traversaient leur
cour, les soldats étaient
agressifs et insultants. Mille
fois, ils ont eu peur de mourir.
Ils trouvent encore, deux
semaines plus tard, des éclats
de shrapnel autour de leur
maison.
La mairesse des deux villages
du coin dit que sa priorité est
d'empêcher que les gens viennent
dans la forêt comme ici, ou
là où les démineurs ne sont
pas encore passés.
Surtout, les Russes ont laissé
derrière eux de vilains cadeaux
après leur défaite autour
de Kiev : des mines de toutes
sortes et des pièges explosifs.
"Des pièges, des grenades,
des mines, tout ce que
les Russes peuvent inventer dans
leur fantaisie", dit Oleksander,
le chef des démineurs.
Comme des grenades dégoupillées
dans le lave-vaisselle,
dans des verres, sous les rampes
d'escalier, dans des remises.
Il y a eu des victimes.
Dans les trois dernières
semaines, les démineurs
de la région de Kiev ont trouvé
plus de 11 000 explosifs,
679 hier seulement.
Voici le risque que posent
les mines.
C'était hier dans la région
de Kharkiv, le chauffeur est
mort sur le coup.
On a trouvé des pièges russes
dans les stations de gaz.
Les démineurs doivent
toutes les inspecter.
Et puis, il y a les maisons
particulières évacuées au début
des combats que les Russes ont
habité pendant leur offensive.
Voici où vivait notre
collaborateur Dima. Il revient
chez lui pour la première fois,
avec les démineurs.
À l'intérieur, des objets ont
été brisés, volés. La maison
a été laissée dans un état
lamentable. Les démineurs n'ont
rien trouvé. Il va falloir tout
nettoyer et réparer.
Les arbres ont été écrasés
par les chars qui stationnaient
dans le jardin.
Depuis 1999, la convention
d'Ottawa interdit l'usage
des mines anti personnelles,
qu'on appelle aussi l'arme des
lâches. 131 pays l'ont signée.
Mais plusieurs ne l'ont pas
encore fait, et pas des
moindres: l'Inde, la Chine,
le Pakistan, les Etats-Unis
et la Russie.
Des soldats en déroute
se sentent-ils le droit
de se venger ainsi sur
la population civile?
"C'est un mystère",
dit Oleksander.
"Je ne peux pas me mettre
dans la tête que quelqu'un
de raisonnable puisse faire ça."
"On peut parler de génocide,
dit la mairesse. Ils veulent
détruire l'Ukraine et le peuple
ukrainien."
Jean-Michel Leprince,